my buddy kicked me up throws me in my
own car takes off it's another car and
just floors it and I always wondered
what that exit looked like to those
other pharmacists
[Music]
[Applause]
his house osaka called the black diary
please one out of applause for mr. sharp
everyone i'm going to tell story about
the kind I walked up a three-story
building fell onto concrete broke my
back in three places and shattered my
heel and I think we're going to have an
injury that bad where you almost died
dr. sticky might be paralyzed it should
be for something you're willing to die
for it right should be for something
important
mine was I was trying to sneak into a
Huey Lewis concert Huey Lewis and the
news are my favorite band of all time
I love Huey Lewis in the news and they
were enormous in the 80s and you know I
grew up in the 80s and then they sort of
you know weren't as big in the 90s and
it turns out they were doing pharmacy
convention in Cleveland Ohio and my
friend was training to be a pharmacist
he was very talented and he turns to me
one day he goes ah hey man I'm going to
this convention tonight for pharmacist
open bar pretty cool also Huey Lewis and
the news are playing it I'm like oh you
got to give me in like that's much
Everett band of all time because I'm
sorry security is very tight I don't
think I can get you in like we'll find
some old guy that doesn't want to party
late and I'll use his credential and he
did I and I went in as Bob Doppel
and creative healthcare solutions from
New Jersey and I'm partying all night
and I end up at like this rich CEO
pharmacy guy's apartment in Cleveland
and it's like amazing and nobody else is
drinking that hard at this point but I'm
still like really hitting it hard
then I yell let's go to the roof
everyone and like now you know it's
really not that kind of roof I wouldn't
do that but I go up there anyway and I'm
so lost in like how beautiful this is
and like how great of an evening it is
that I just kind of like walk clean off
the roof and fall three stories I just
thought I had a little bit more room you
know like I'll have you've ever walked
down steps and you think you got another
step and you don't yo like I thought I
had another style step of roof and it
was not there I fall down I don't know
how long I'm unconscious for I later
learned that inside this room and the
party like I go up somebody let's go to
the roof like that's not a good idea
they later turn to my friend and they go
is he gonna be okay and he goes Bob
Doppel this is the most mistake proof
pharmacist I know they didn't see me
fall through the window I hit the ground
I don't know how long I'm unconscious
for I come to and I'm like triply
confused because I have all these
strangers above me and they're going Bob
Bob Bob and that's when it hits me I go
oh they think I'm Bob Doppel in
creative healthcare solution and I panic
because I was relatively certain I was
going to die for my injuries so I think
to myself oh my god I'm about to die and
they're going to call Bob topples wife
but she's going to get this phone call
like Bob's dad like what happened heart
attack stroke like no he walked off a
three-story building so I set up and I
go I don't care what happens next
nobody talked to my wife I just fall
down to die my buddy
picks me up throws me in my own car
takes off hits another car and just
floors it and I always wondered what
that exit looked like to those other
pharmacists they had to be like wow that
new jersey office parties
[Laughter]
Bob topples just walked off a building
told us not to tell his wife and I think
it's friend just stole a goddamn vehicle
and we're driving now in this vehicle my
car and my buddy turns he's like oh my
god Flannery I saw you fought through
that window I thought you were dead
like me - brother I did - got ever see
again man
he's like geez I panicked I didn't know
what am I gonna do if you die I know I
know I know you wanna know what's weird
as I was falling I thought I was going
to die but I was totally comfortable
because I was singing the power of love
in my head and I was at total peace he
starts laughing so hard he loses control
of my car and hits a tree so I have now
been in two major accidents in about 45
second no if they get to the core of the
power of love in 45 seconds I've been in
two major collision we get out of the
car we walk back to his apartment I go
to bed I think I'm fine I wake up the
next day and I feel a little sore I go
into the ER and that's when I realize
that I was so drunk I literally walked
off a roof and I didn't know I was
falling so I didn't bend my leg so the
force of the fall compressed my first
three vertebrae I got a compression
fracture in my the surgeon that was
looking at the x-rays with them is of
whoa whoa no aah
this would mean you made no effort to a
judge
like at all no I mean look at 7-eleven
clerk looking like a $20 bill or like
not saying everything the injury and
anyone under the age of 92 he brought in
another surgeon to look at it like just
to show them and I will never forget
what that other surgeon said to its
residents as long as I live he held up
the x-ray to go this young man right
here he walked off a roof I am talking
Daffy Duck style this is medical his
medical terminology for how I injured
myself but what was amazing is they both
agreed that being drunk saved my life
because they said that if I would sober
I would have realized that was falling I
would have braced for impact it would
have changed my center of gravity and I
might have hit my head
I learned that evening that every fall
over 10 feet is legal if you had your
head
so they said being drunk actually saved
your life now the nurse overheard this
since she goes courts sober person may
not have been on that roof
[Laughter]
you know ma'am we don't need to
cherry-pick science here okay so ladies
and gentlemen I don't know if there's
nothing immoral this story but if you
find yourself like on an unfamiliar roof
just exploring at night please dear God
in the interest of safety be drunk out
of your mind
thank you very much
[Applause]